c'est une console de jeux qui va nous
raconter des histoires dieux dans
laquelle nous serons les héros et nous
allons devoir résoudre une série
d'énigmes pour progresser dans les
histoires et peut-être sauver le monde
et donc le mécanisme de jeu chaque
chapitre c'est un peu comme un escape
game on a une heure de jeu pendant
laquelle on va résoudre 5 à 10 énigmes
en coopération avec nos amis ou la
famille
[Musique]
le bilan il est très positif dans le
sens où on a fait beaucoup de rencontres
des contacts avec la presse américaine
ça c'est plutôt très bien passé et même
pas que la presse américaine puisqu'il y
avait des journalistes un peu du monde
entier qui sont présents lors du CES et
puis sur l'aspect distribution c'est la
même chose en fait c'est assez fou mais
on a eu des événements où on a pu
rencontrer des distributeurs du monde
entier aussi ça nous a permis aussi
d'avoir des gens qui viennent tester sur
notre stand on avait préparé une petite
démo pour le ces donc des retours
d'expérience on a même des gens qui
étaient parmi nos premiers clients qui
ont fait les précommandes qui sont venus
nous voir lors du CES et qui était
ravi de pouvoir avoir l'objet dans les
mains
on est en pleine phase
d'industrialisation alors nous allons
terminer d'industrialisation lancer la
production cet été et livré à nos
premiers clients pour Noël de cette
année
[Musique]